je travaille avec des gens assez marrant
eux
notamment christophe salengro qui amène
une distance un humour
l'humour c'est ce qu'incarne et
christophe salengro aux yeux de philippe
decouflé
car saviez vous qu avant d'être le
célèbre président de groland l'émission
de canal+
le comédien dansait dans la compagnie du
chorégraphe c'est en 1986 que salengro
intègre la troupe pour le spectacle
codex joué au festival d'avignon
s'allongeront qu'est ce que vous faites
dans cette galère eh bien
en avignon depuis que francis steurs
jouer le cid ça ça un peu bloqué tous
mes roues alors voilà je me retrouve
avec philippe découflé et
mais se veut agréable vraiment c'est un
spectacle extrêmement sympathique fidèle
complice du chorégraphe christophe
salengro s'impose alors comme l'un des
piliers de la compagnie en février 1992
il participe aux festivités d'ouverture
et de clôture des jeux olympiques
d'albertville mis en scène par philippe
decouflé
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs soyez les
bienvenus au théâtre en plein air
d'albertville en savoie la savoie qui
s'honore de votre venue
et vous donne aujourd'hui le bon jour
par ma voix la multiprise les deux
hommes enchaîneront ensuite les
collaborations à travers ses nombreux
spectacles
le chorégraphe cherchait toujours à
cultiver les particularités physiques et
comique de sa langue a cité la fée
électricité
voilà je crois que j'aime bien les gens
assez personnalisé et il aime bien se
soit pas forcément onze personnes
exactement pareil donc il joue beaucoup
avec les différences entre les gens et
c'est pour ça qu'il veut aussi des gens
comme moi qui sont pas vraiment dans son
alors on les reconnaît reconnaît les
différences longueur de cheveux ont tous
leur des vêtements au fait qu'il a des
lunettes est pas l et à quelques autres
points plus difficile à percevoir sur ce
bon soir au sein de la compagnie
christophe salengro participaient aussi
à la conception et à l'écriture de
certains spectacles une association
fusionnelle que le comédien a évoqué en
1995 on se connaît depuis dix ans et on
consomme et puis on on s'engueule aussi
pas mal des rapports créatifs comme je
vais remonter parce que j'ai mal aux
jambes
christophe salengro a été vu pour la
dernière fois sur scène en 2014 dans la
création contact de son fidèle
chorégraphe
le comédien est décédé le 30 mars 2018 à
paris il avait 64 ans
ça
[Musique]